ринок на укол йти варшави шуста роки на
ранку
Павло Сапковський пробивши тут немає
джоппер щі клієнти приходять у ж втраті
Павло малина продажів 2 тонни бубей али
всього разу бізнес ви взагалі немає вже в
дав їм вже закласти вигляд з досвіду у джо
рапп досвід би дізнатися на машині шп руку
зація теж сенату жива статі довелося а
ставка ти з витрат і плескати на їжу з
вічним торговцем вин студент при
чому-небудь та а в одному дізнайся wedge
престижних вище україни
варшавський вищій школі економіки
здавати я страшний у туман і лісовик почищу
зуби і в моє обличчя
Павло вже 30 води на ногах olumu медуз
ну тат і райдужки заняття в університеті
символ to win завершуючи на вч вони теж
важливі ось образ клас ти випробував вона
адже з дипломом престижного економічного
вищу йому не просто знає і роботу
кирки студентів у porsche всю руку
заростаючи нині їх повтору мільйона теж
конкуренція лику
роботу заходьте лиж і краше з крадіжках на
адже за протестом польська економіка нила
пари жива підйом робочих місць всім на
вас така нині в краї не близько 200 5 10
тисяч безробітних молодих спеціалістів
не думаю що чернець туз відео на роботу я
про мій будь не поки що за аліни
думаю за моїм гуманітарним хахом
перспективи лякані добре знайти роботу
якобс правду allow чиковани багата
молодих людей просто виїжджати країни
так і хто хоче вихід і багато і сарат
однокурсників павла Дурова
формуємо сполох жити перспективи зруби
то кар'єру запаху
на батьківщині так ванною найважливішим
пробки найбільша проблема насташа
робочих місць дата вашої закінчать кивати
ти відриваєш просто смішно зарплат його
а ви мій виліт 6 відс і давати хоч
обама мало 10 руки в стажу проти
пік даремно на ентузіазмі navi що мета
цілісний музло його доброго дня знижки
кішки 13 злотих відьма, що поїхала
по 12 ну добре для такої роботи ос види
у вищій школі економіки на потрібно
візок дівається перепродати очорнити і
дорожче а б полону і мені повернуть з убив
страшний і на губах його потенційний
клієнт відома хлопця свистну Павло Марія
про нашу кар'єру
аланар азіза задоволений і тим що травня на
планету сунувся для нього на інший план